(car engine revving)
(evil laugh)
- Come on Puddin', do it!
- Oh, we have got company.
- Batsy, Batsy, Batsy.
Stupid Bats, you're ruining date night.
(gun firing)
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Little spoiler alert there.
Batman's in the movie.
Yeah, Batman is in the film.
Jared, you tried out
different laughs, didn't you?
For the Joker.
Was it very difficult for you
to come up with the right laugh?
Was it, I mean, how
annoying a process is that?
- The Joker's laugh is an iconic thing,
so there was a lot of pressure.
I tried a lot of different laughs out
on the streets of New York and Toronto.
(laughing)
- People just thought
something was wrong with you.
- Yeah, yeah.
I had one that I knew wasn't right.
It was kind of like.
Hihihi.
(audience laughing)
- [Conan] That's not really good, yeah.
- [Jared] I don't know,
maybe you liked that.
I'm not sure.
(laughing)
- It's like a shy debutante.
Karen, his laugh really bothered you.
- Yeah, well, whenever I met Jared,
he never broke character.
So, I would say, I'm Karen Fukuhara.
Nice to meet you, I'm Katana
and then he would over you with,
"Ha ha ha, hi pretty".
That was the worst impression ever.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, Jared.
- I thought it was pretty good.
(audience clapping)
A very good wicked witch.
That was excellent.
- You have to teach me.